sta ballando tutti gli account ma
ti odio genna ti dà volto un figlio era
assolutamente benvenuti così proveremo
un nuovissimo gioco pauroso che super
popolare in questo periodo su rob lowe a
75mila mi piego benissimo che
presto presto ok ok sono qui con te che
cosa ci aspetta la comandava stata un
bel mezzo di questo video raggiunge i 5
mila mi piace proveremo un'altra storia
da loro blog anzi consigliate ce l'ha
pure qua sotto nei commenti
ecco che stiamo volando
l'altro andare allora sembra sembra
esserci una casa prima 1 la casa di
genova e via
ciao ragazzi finalmente siete arrivati
abbiamo solo due ore per il fino al
prossimo shawbak ok andiamo per ora non
sembra paurosa sembra tutto tranquillo
ma voi sapete che all'inizio è sempre
tutto tranquillo e poi iniziano le cose
paurose genna sta arrivando dice questo
vecchietto
ignoratelo è un vecchio pazzo
siccome è la prima volta che inter casa
mia poi esplorare un po
siamo siamo tantissimi siamo 10 tipo
ricucire il ritratto aprendo qua
inquietante come vice è una mia foto no
c'è una cosa orribile che vantano non
trovavo il frigo l'ho trovato
hai trovato qualcosa o ancora niente
anche io il quadro con il mio quadro qui
dai prezzi dobbiamo cercare qualche
indizio voi prima che arrivi c'è cosa è
successo la giocata è enorme si grazie
è un po strano questo ragazzo abbiamo
velocità però giochiamo giochiamo a
nascondino di scoprire o perfetto ok
giochiamo e scommettiamo di sole
addirittura detto che era un po strano e
io mi nascondo e chiunque mi trony 150
dollari secondo me dovrebbe essere una
trappola già no l'altro va trovato nel
bagno premuto con i tre secondi non un
altro voto io
ricordo 50 dollari nono solo di adesso e
non puoi fare promesse che non puoi
mantenere e va bene vi comprerò delle
patatine fritte potete nuotare nella mia
piscina dei contento
che bello ok allora togliamo le patatine
andiamo a nuotare in piscina ei ma chi è
questa genna è vero ancora non si è
vista
qualcuno si e buttando i migliori sono
stato smentito
e dicono è in realtà è genoa potrebbe
essere un hacker un hacker un hacker che
senso e lasciatemi spiegare ok spiega
genna che era duro blocks e vuole
appropriarsene
traballando tutti gli account mai
successo
ma che cos'è la quello tedesco colpito
non solo siamo sul vetro ma io sono già
detto credo che stia agendo
genova mi aveva colpito perché lui ha
detto qualcosa di lei ha rivelato che
lei e un hacker che vuole davvero è
stato colpito da un martello
poverino è stata agenda secondo bambola
bambina ma l'etica quindi è un hacker
quindi vuol dire che è stato bannato
dell'azienda no non voglio che ballino
il mio account rob lowe 15mila sono vere
[Musica]
guarda il telegiornale cosa dice gemma
che ride la per genna è arrivato
nascondetevi nella casa
15 banda dal gioco dovremmo andare nel
ripostiglio che di cui parlano non
voglio essere bannato perderò tutto dico
io che io voglio essere passato non
potra fare gameplay d'ora non abbiamo
scelta dobbiamo andare dove dobbiamo
andare
sono macchine genna la rimando genoa
contenuta a quella macchina
ecco il martello di genna o meglio
allontanarsi che succede ecco nuovamente
genna e vera motivo forse una limousine
ok eravamo noi imbattuti nel mio
ripostiglio
nascondiglio grazie per averci accolto
ok andiamo allora è un piacere prezzo
entrate e il gra mica posso vedere il po
ma c'è anche da mangiare né è molto
grande ma è sicuro ok bene qui abbiamo
dei strano sappiamo il suo per fare una
basta qui ha visto
ovviamente vitarelli davanti al sig
ok questa per dormire a dormire perfetto
allora il dormire al suo posto dobbiamo
pianificare come sconfiggere genna
verificare come sconfiggere giorno ma
prima incontrato il mio amico ok chi è
il tuo miei metà girava a metà loro blog
e che cosa forse era meglio genoa
togliete il letto su cui dormire o per
dio lontano dall'uomo mezzo giraffa me
pure io mi metto qui in zona finestra no
aspetto vicino alla finestra forse
meglio di no perché noto qua
perché magari arriva agenda ma dove sono
sparite io ma quindi quando vai a letto
si è sprofondato proprio no mi sa che ho
già scelto quel letto non posso cambiare
e ho pensato che avete fame si porta
tablet
ce n'è uno per tutti non abbiamo molto
cibo
no questa è una notizia brutta dov'è il
cibo non lo so
vitale qualche cerca il cibo per favore
ho fame
datemi il vostro cibo
no no mangiamo e cibo e se votare o
mangi cibo lo della giraffa bene è
meglio che lo mangiamo noi no eh sì che
le giraffe adesso se raiola mi dispiace
ma non possiamo darti la nostra cibo
vabbè di la giraffa ma come ti chiami
comunque infatti dice che stanotte ci fa
a fette shark mame shardna in che non è
strano
ehi ma non sei un amministratore si
andando dopo tanto tempo fa con russa
c'è qualcosa di strano
o no giorno è la sola e si asciugano
arrivato presto seguitemi il piano aiuto
aiuto aiuto
mi
chiamo uscite da giù dalle scale e
adesso che ci siamo rifugiati qua a
prometterlo fare paura se avete già il
mio libro story parole as quali misteri
in tanti se vivete scritto che avete già
preso la pausini mi fa piacere se non ce
l'avete ancora applicata in ligue des
twitter per prendere sui vetri nei
commenti se lo avete preso dice che
dobbiamo prendere ma non per difenderci
e pero essere abbastanza per tutti e va
dove sono non ne trovo dobbiamo aprire
queste scatole per prenderlo ok però
siamo pronti a difenderci d'azienda ok
vi ricordate nel coraggio genna non
riuscirai a bannare mio siamo proprio te
non combattiamo finiremo bannati o no
non amo essere bannati altrimenti non
potremo più fare gameplay potremo più
fare video ieri si sta picchiando eccolo
il giorno visto che mi ami della squadra
e di genna con i vestitini a rossano
degli hacker vedi aiuto
aiutata una paninoteca modo così
hanno rubato i siti rimini aveva perso
la mazza loro erano anche e questo è
solo l'inizio o che ha detto confortante
ha giocato meno hanno preso tommy
andiamo a controllare ciò che lui ha
detto che protegge la porta ok dobbiamo
cercare tommy il primo no guarda ha
fatto una brutta fine tommy l'anno
spiccicato ma chi è questo
dopo amministratore cous cous credo che
dobbiamo sconfiggerlo
adesso arriverà come sapete la mazza
freddo ma lancia pure le giornate dove
giulia la vita devo allontanarmi
assolutamente ancora aspetta dobbiamo
aspettare quando li si smette di girare
gli rimangono scorsa può perché curate
la mia barra della vita è quasi esaurito
oro bannata non possa essere barbata ma
ma devo scappare quando si ferma mai di
girare questo non lo posso salire dopo
adesso adesso si è fermato poi colpiamo
lo colpivano tutti insieme
l'abbiamo quasi eliminato prevede che il
tiro qualche colpa line alla grande a 1
si è risvegliato scappa scappa
nascondermi da qualche parte o più
definita sta sparando due allora bando
mia spiaccicato
un nuovo vitale vitale stato sfracellato
è siamo riusciti però a eliminare per un
amministratore per un troviamo tom no
guardate cosa hanno fatto
sono distrutto il rifugio
no dobbiamo andare sul soffitto è
cromata prova è stato hackerato
anche lui è stato hackerato quindi loro
ora sono tipo al servizio di genna
perché gli arrestati hanno il martello
loro erano i miei migliori amici mi
mancano anche le quindi se vini ha
tirato ti trasformi in uno il servizio
di giorno con il vassallo non
fatevi prendere sono molto forti come
facciamo può stare lì senza farci
prendere
difficilissimo allora è un iphone mai
subito destra dai primi sono troppo
lento ebbene sono accorto non c'è pure
tempo insomma impossibile
fai in modo che la gente non così lento
non se n'è accorto non se n'è accorto
bravata siamo rimasti in tre
giusto il tempo un luogo di rob lowe a
spiaccica doors un ritardo dobbiamo
trovare una persona che il bilderberg
presto eccola sensore
dove potrebbe essere dobbiamo trovare la
stanza di questo mi dico che stiamo
cercando che potrà aiutarci a
sconfiggere jersey è un labirinto co c'è
qualcosa sì sembra che ci sia tipo un
pulsante wow è un labirinto
forse ci siamo quasi sophis conferma
però non mi bastano solo si fa salire il
palazzo adesso abbiamo un primate mani
lo provino
biedermann qui è
buono è stato trasformato in pietra la
sostanza è distrutta controlliamo le
sofia ok dove sta vendendo prima quindi
è facile da sola è così siamo sul
soffitto
eccolo il nostro amico è stato eliminato
al mare
non lo so andiamo a vedere
mi sa che hanno bannato anche lui
poverino
una trappola era una boa
poverino giraffino ciò che dico io tante
ora come faremo ecco genna
stato bisogno diversa se vi avvicinate a
lui morirete haber siete molto
coraggiosi ok quindi l'hacker atorno rob
lowe xvi ha quindi starò blocks certo
non lo vedete poco ora che ho catturato
il builder man posso finalmente
comandare giocherò blocks mamma ma voi
siete molto coraggiosi e avete scoperto
che sono è finito adesso di formare bot
roma telefonate ci sarà una battaglia
all'ultimo sangue senso solo in tre non
so se oggi stanno piovendo delle cose
verdi allora aspetta troviamo un modo di
colpire agenda fino a sfumato conti
sfacelo
dai ok sono rinata non mi frega sola non
ce la farò mai da sola
vai vai
ok ragazzi proviamo l'ultima volta ma
credo che da solo non ce la farò
ma aspetta un momento allora non mi devo
avvicinare cosa devo fare forse devo
colpire questa cosa qua amici che cos'è
la testa a testa con un martello che si
stava inseguendo si stanno lanciando i
martelli ok no no stanno funzionando
ok ragazzi pronti ma volta altrimenti
sarà acclarata per sempre capisco forse
quelle cose lì sparano altre altre cose
non ti avvicinano 13 9 che quello
esplode che cosa devo fare
devi colpirlo adesso vedi che adesso che
no non ho capito
aspetta che jenna sia stanca sempre top
ok aspettiamo
attenta
e ultimo più più aiuto basta burkhard
stanchi
fra poco la fra poco fra poco il
difficilissimo
attentando non vigilate troppo le
varie penso che adesso stanca
decadi mai mai mai ancora
la sua la sua barra sta diminuendo
ok dobbiamo avere molta pazienza penso
che da solo è più difficile
nascondiamoci qua
a
martellate
aiuto è
difficilissimo
[Musica]
ok forse se mi nascondo fa non riesce a
prendermi in b ci aspettiamo che sia
stanca
[Musica]
ce la faremo a sconfiggere il bel
tempo
beccati questa agenda prima o poi doveva
ammontare lontane di premi che si
sveglia
ho pochissima vita
devi di nasconderti no è appreso ok sono
rinato di nuovo no vabbè non ci credo
lasciate un mi piace solo per tutti i
robots che sta spendendo per dai
napoletani sanità spiaccicata
la stretta è adesso si deve stancare
minuto tra poco inizia a danzare i
martelli street alla chat già
sappiamo che abbiamo scappiamo che ora
dovrebbe staccarsi
colpiamo la più possibile
fra poco devi scappare però è altrimenti
di riprender
non mi ascolta ma ieri darà voce ai
master odio mi becca sempre con i
martelli
dai suoi risparmi li potrebbe molto poco
dato molto positivo per me lo so che mi
piace per me no
dai sette
decadi questo mago fa già nati o di
risposta di grande sollievo nei martelli
se tu ti odio genna ti devo sconfiggere
assolutamente che io
pensavo che qua dietro sarei stato
protetto e arrivano anche qua tra poco
puoi andare
[Musica]
ok mai
quante volte mancheranno allontanati
vabbè come un 8 a stringere dubbio i
banchi solo una volta e poi riuscire a
sconfiggerla devo stare solo sperticate
attentissimo adesso martelli parte di
martelli a youtube forte riesco a
sconfiggerlo questa volta attori steve
lee forse ce la facciamo a chi sta
prendendo però mai attacca aiuto attacca
attacca non c'è fretta e ancora ancora
ancora
a
brava non ci credo ai sconfitto ger non
ci credo finalmente ce l'abbiamo fatta
se ce l'hai fatta dice tutte le a milano
di spiaccicate sono arrivati mi i corpi
significati e b barberis è ripreso no no
non ci credo e successo la l'ultima
volta b che l'ultima cosa che mi ricordo
a vedere gente che entrava nel mio
ufficio ha preso il controllo di tutela
bannato tutti per controllare rho blocks
vado abbiamo pronto per ora abbiamo
perso un sacco di amici però anche vita
sì c'è qualcosa che possiamo fare per
fare in modo di togliere il bagno a
tutti forse ho qualcosa
che può aiutare in questo lavoro è
premere il bottone
detto così torneremo una settimana fa
ok premino subito
ok via 32 dura
7 giorni palma
che cede
1 milione di un box per aver salvato gen
e per aver salvato rho blocks non so io
questa cosa in testa di un cappello tipo
non ci credo non ci sono vinto la
lotteria
beh non credermi se vuoi wow sei
riuscito a completare
già
abbiamo detto
a tutti i fan non siamo stati mondo mio
sito e li trovo bene è stato un po mi
piace per vedere altre storie roberts e
aromi la stiamo qua 4 casellina su cui
cliccare per vedere inoltre altri video
a caps quella che preferite buona vita
ciao